so do you think erica kind of had a play
in how
everything went down after she smashed
the hourglass
no
absolutely not she smashed the hourglass
like he was like oh like what should i
go do now i just want to talk to
everyone hi i'm working communications
like i love her she's funniest like
no
zero play she smashed the thing which i
would have done too and that was the end
congrats you smashed it
and you risked nothing in the process so
that was my next question like if you
were in her position would you have
smashed it too
that would have been like you could
reverse the course of and i would have
just hit that
i would have been like i'm smashing i
don't get there's no question anything
that can see safety in the game because
you never know what's going to happen i
said at the beginning my strategy is to
see tomorrow and like she got to see
tomorrow literally because of that so
there's so many twists especially with
41 the season of advantages
like of course like of course but i was
surprised that she didn't have to risk
your vote
or anything
or risk five votes honestly now i'm
thinking about it like change the course
of history risk 25 votes risk your vote
for the next time you get invited back
but no she didn't have to risk a thing
she just had to risk maybe being hated
by some people which is funny because i
hate everyone but i don't hate her for
that
that's amazing how hard was the
challenge where you just had to use your
feet you were actually really good at
that though thank you i don't think it
was very hard because it was more about
core strength
so
as for my beautiful obliques on the
season like you can see like episode
after episode it wasn't like that that
difficult but that flag oh my god that
flag so of course like the only person i
lost to was a dancer and i'm not a
dancer so
how did you feel to see ricard win like
within seconds of you taking it
oh everyone's like yay and i'm like
like yay
like if it it could have been anyone i
don't care but if it's not me then i'm
pissed so it could have been required it
could have been shawn and kim and evie i
would have had the same reaction the
same reaction even danny who i love like
his family like i
would have been like hey
god jerry
it seemed like everyone was going for
evie and deshawn last night so how did
it end up being you
uh yeah good question so i was exactly
where i wanted to be i wanted to be
liked by almost everybody and i said
that from the jump because if you're
liked by everybody you're a target and
deshawn and evie are so likable and so
it's like it was them but then
lyanna's failed
knowledge is power attempt and then like
paranoia and then where the idols were
placed and like kind of how the
alliances
like branched off like i
i had fostered relationships with people
i wanted to work with that was danny
deshawn
tiffany evie and xander so i was very
much in the middle which is where i
wanted to be
but in that situation
where so few people are actually
eligible and then there are also like
these advantages floating around i
i'm not dumb
like i know like at this point
this is this is me being unfortunate
collateral to a million twists in the
game coming together in one moment so
yeah it's great cbs wanted to like
change things up but in the process they
lost their most entertaining players so
hope your ratings go down
that is fact i was gonna say you are so
entertaining to watch
what was your favorite part about
watching yourself because i know you say
you're a little self-obsessed which we
love to see
thank you
i'd say like my favorite part of
watching myself is like watching myself
like any time i even had to catch a
glimpse of my hair i'm like look at that
hot split end i'm like uh like obsessed
i was like
and everything i said was golden because
like people are nervous about their
edits like oh i hope i don't come across
as boring i wasn't nervous i'm like
nothing i said was boring so i'm never
gonna have a boring moment and like
i really do think
the editors were like giving me some
like really authentic me like hate me
because they hate me me being
self-obsessed like
me being a mermaid they really like me
wanting to travel with my daddy's credit
card like that is funny that is me and
like
they gave me zingers so i i appreciate
that editors
you can spear fish did you know that
about yourself before you went into this
no so like i actually one of the best
pieces of advice i got like before i
went on the show was like like don't be
like that fisher not specifically a
fisherman but like they are away from
the tribe for so long like you're going
to be like missing out on prime moments
of like strategizing but
we're on a winning tribe we had time
like at one point there was it kind of
went at bay
and it was a challenge where like danny
like almost fainted
we come to learn that like he was faking
it but at that moment because he didn't
want to seem super strong with the merge
approaching but in that moment i was
like god like i need to feed danny he
won't eat the bread fruit he won't eat
the coconut because like he had like
this gag reflex and also danny doesn't
like people like taking care of him like
oh my god danny drank so i'm like i'm
just gonna do it i'm not gonna say
anything like this like he's my number
one like this man needs to eat
so i'm like i'm just gonna do it and it
was
so much fun like i do consider myself to
be naturally athletic so like i didn't
think i would catch nothing i just
didn't think i would catch as much as i
did
and it's like it's become like this
obsession like i went spearfishing last
weekend in mexico like my bar trip after
i take the bar like i'm going to the
philippines to spearfish for like a
month like that is my plan so that was
yeah that was like definitely a
highlight and a tangible thing i could
take from the show is like something
that i truly enjoy in my life
that is a new hobby that's amazing that
you figured that out
so last night it was your first tribal
did you have a feeling walking into your
first tribal that it would be your last
um
no but then i never felt safe at the
same time like
my biggest like fear coming into the
show i take that back because i was
getting out first but like one of my
biggest things that i was like scared of
was
feeling safe and then getting eliminated
in america being like one idiot so i
made a conscious effort to never make
like feel safe and i never did feel safe
ever like there was a point where
deshawn's like i think i'm gonna play my
shot in the dark and maybe he was saying
that to mess with me or whatever but i'm
like
you know like i'm kind of between these
alliances and like this ugh
so
i
knew what was probably going to happen
when it wasn't happening i wasn't
shocked so
i just i wanted to put my feet in my own
hands and not those losers
were you shocked that xander had the
fake idol
it's funny because i knew everything
that was happening that tribal
everything except that
so
i was surprised but i
give the kids so much respect for that
move and at that point i still didn't
think i was like out out because i was
still like good with them like i was
still good and i'm like they kept it
among the family i don't blame them i
would have done that too right so like
it was it was an awesome play
um
but like
i was like shocked i was like
it's
21 like who cares
like it happens like congrats you made a
fake idol like it was a great play and
was done right but like you're not the
first person to make a fake idol
what do you think of shannon's gameplay
because she's tricking everyone
oh she's playing phenomenal like i think
she has an error about her that's
like you just immediately drawn in like
i remember like having some pushback
like we had one conversation she's like
oh no no like no we can't do that and i
was like
okay fine and it was almost like that
helped because when people are like so
agreeable you never know what to believe
but when they're actually giving you a
little bit of pushback that
adds credence to like them in general so
i think shan is
playing
like the perfect amount hard but not
like this crazy aggressive like she gave
lyanna
the advantage she gave it but then she
took advantage like it's it's a it's
really
as a fan of the show like
i respect it i respect your name a lot
that leads to my next question who do
you think deserves to win just by seeing
the game play so far
i mean i think sham is a huge contender
and deserving to win i think xander
after like that move
definitely deserving to win and i think
tiffany
also just
she as a like an older woman they
traditionally don't do as well but like
she was obviously besides the balance
balance beam she was like she did every
challenge like she on that island with
me her and brad was like i don't need my
vote it's like talk about like your
social
genius to literally be able to say with
full confidence and then walk the walk i
don't need my vote so i would say
probably those three
um so did you prefer to be on the island
with your tribe or did you like the
merge better
uh merge next question literally
oh they're like lulu strong i was like
no
no
way maybe because i was with them for so
long like i will say like
danny and sean like we spent hours
laughing like if i didn't have them i
would have gone crazy like we laughed
and laughed and laughed and laughed and
just like the jokes we had were just
hilarious but i
i like
i like the dynamic shift and i i need i
really really needed it i really needed
it
would you do anything differently or do
you just love how if
you were on the tv screen and like would
you do anything differently for your
gameplay or do you wish you would have
said some things
one-liners um i would i couldn't have
done i really couldn't have done
anything differently like truly i was
exactly where i said i wanted to be in
the middle of alliances like by almost
everybody not everybody it's like i
executed my plan right like i had good
trust but i was also like
willing to like cut like everything so
i
they i wasn't beat by the players i was
beat by the game and like there's
nothing i can do about that so
everything that i had in my power
i executed phenomenally and in terms of
one-liners like i was so filled with one
liner so it's like maybe they could have
edited in more but like i already had so
much screen time obviously like given
like the circumstances like they
literally could like literally in good
faith
could not
um so this was the
hardest season yet season 41. what was
the hardest part for you
funny
because i came in thinking like it was
going to be survived like the survival
aspect and like i backpacked the world
with like just a literal backpack like
i know i'm fine in the elements like i
have a good temperature control like
i've slept in altitude i've like biked
in thailand torrential storm but i
really thought that like
no matter what i still was fed and it's
like i
like i love food i'm such fat like
i'm like i that's going to be so hard
for me like i literally cried so many
days leading up to the games i'm like
this is
miserable everyone's so excited to play
survivor i'm like dude imagine sleeping
without a blanket like oh my god but the
hardest part for me ended up being the
people which is like funny because i'm
so social like
i have a lot of friends like i have a
good social life like
i grew up with three brothers like
i do have a lot of patience everything
in my life has
kind of led me in the direction of
people right like extroverted gregarious
but
it was really really hard to live with
the same people with zero dynamic change
for two weeks and
that was by far the hardest part like
the survival ended up being
one of the easier parts for me so
everyone's like no rice starvation i'm
just like
yeah we had breadfruit which is gross i
think i'd literally rather just eat my
toes but
like it's funny how it worked out
because the hardest part for me was
the people so now i'm like i love being
a loner
would you do any other reality tv show
because you are just like made for
reality tv oh thank you yeah i mean i'm
just an i'm an opportunist like i'll
take anything that comes my way so
like
i don't i watch survivor obviously but
like i don't watch too many of the other
ones people are like caster for this
caster for this like yeah i'll start
watching [ __ ] i would love to do more
reality tv i love the camera i always
have always will
um
100 like cast me also like i need money
i'm a student so like play me please
like literally i'm so broke i'm so
fiscally irresponsible
do you have any advice for up and call
coming uh survivor contestants
ooh
my advice for up and coming survivor
contestants would be to play the way i
played
like
no but like seriously it's like one of i
guess here's a better thing would be
i went in being like trust is bleeding
like i don't know if i need it i'll kind
of see what happens
like you you have to you have to like if
i didn't have danny
like
i think i would have probably just like
lost faith in humanity like on that
island because like he really
like ride or died for me and you need
that peace of mind at the least because
like the paranoia is so uh
so like as much as trust is annoying and
trust is broken
trust is so much
harder to create than it is to break
so i look back
at like the
jd vote where everyone's like jd and
genie should have used the extra vote to
get out shana ricard but they already
like sure but they already didn't trust
each other like the moment you say
something like that then it's like
you're scared that they'll tell the
other person then you're just
immediately so you're almost better off
putting your fate in other people's
hands so it's like creating that trust
early is so important because breaking
it easy is
creating it
almost impossible almost impossible
my last question what one word would sum
up your whole survivor experience
ooh
um
i would just say
with dashes never before seen
that's amazing well thank you so much
for talking to me sydney and i wish you
all the best and i hope to see you on tv
again soon
thanks appreciate it